die Menschen können sich sicher sein das
Gesetz von Robert Habeck wird so nicht
kommen wie das ursprünglich wurde wie
sie das Betonen ja weil das der Punkt
warum wir nicht aussieht dass das Gesetz
von Robert habe auf gar keinen Fall so
kommt es hat nichts mit der Person zu
tun Inhalt zu tun dass die Menschen
heute schon keinen Termin bekommen beim
Schornsteinfeger beim Energieberater bei
den Leuten die man mal fragen kann was
ist denn jetzt eigentlich mit meiner
Heizung da ist eine riesiges Maß an
Unzufriedenheit weil sie dazu betonen
dieses böse gesetzt hätte nicht
erschließen können und deswegen ist es
gut dass ich damals verändert hat weil
sie das so betonen dass dieses böse habe
ich gesetzlich kommt sie haben ja als
FDP zweimal in diesem Gesetz zugestimmt
zweimal in der Bundesregierung ja aber
ich bin ja Parlamentarier ja aber ich
weiß
FDP absolut und wir entscheiden aber im
Bundestag ja selber was wir aufsetzen
und was nicht der Bundestag ist ja nicht
die abnick Vorrichtung für die Regierung
[Musik]